yahoo che merda
guardi che merda guarda che merda che
merita uccisi oggi avviene apr gente
oddio non è vero quanto la vela d'oro
[Musica]
scoraggiato lanciato lasciato motori ma
perché nessun problema cesiss non
spaccare blocchi fare con che sta
arrivando gesto
porque no di qua non c'è una palla da
brescia bs si ferma che ridere
europea ci voglio andare questo e tropea
rovente zecca madonna azzeccato mi
illudevo minuto quando sono uscito
metti tropea non basta non guardiamo
niente partite roberta e succede questa
cosa lo fai è venuta a milano per uscire
con me si è detto milano milano chiuso
ma può molto ma io non sto capendo in
africa rigori toriello quando la tua
crush si avvicina a te ti sussurra
nell'orecchio
stasera ho casa libera a casa libera
stasera perché si afferma questa non
corno che sei scema rago questi cieli
problema te lo meriti anche un
pochettino in realtà è che lo meriti
abbastanza in tutto questo ragazzi posso
farvi una domanda ma la polizia che hai
fatto fuori campo zio
attenzione proprio lui vorrà in un
casino casino sto facendo casino per
fare fratelli non ci credo a posso
diventare un delfino cosa è successo
secondo me lei per non farti male quindi
per non tirarti lo shock svegliarti
secondo me telo su chiaro
voi non capite voi non state capendo
quello è satana e satana come basta
partito la mattina a chi è stato ma la
macchina cartellino a metà con l'alito
marzo l'azienda non lo sto provato i
pasti giugno eccomi verso la macchina
cene stesso uno ti dice di ammazza la
moglie lo fa io ma che sei scemo parte i
guai è pieno di coda
[Musica]
una donna può c'è un bambino che correva
stupidissimo l'ho visto ma che ho forza
buttana cosa ho visto cosa ho visto via
via che è brutto gioco di brutto giorno
giovane sì
bahrami state parcheggio qua ora questa
cosa di acqua
gianpi sei pronto
no però non sei pronto nonno blu che
cazzo sto vedendo mamma mia come va
benissimo benissimo panaro lo rifacciamo
domani domani quattro donne io no e
video no però non hai capito no però non
è così
[Musica]
il catena delle nouvelles a degli anni
80 ecco le foto casa è così per il fondo
o mio dio devo uscire da quella da
quella porta li devo uscire io chiudi
quella porta va l'atto di questa porta
questa porta qui non si apre non sia
prima della destra la destra non devo
andare a destra
devo andare a destra non mi non mi
saltare addosso per cortesia
insomma lasciato sorrisi per facebook
stato che segue la polizia si prende
temi che sono ho visto cose sto cercando
una killer
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi spero che la vita vi sia
piaciuto come al solito viene piaciuto
lascia un documento è un bel mi piace al
video sosta quali siti iscrivetevi e noi
come sempre ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]